TAO DONG: My name is Tao Dong.
I'm a UX researcher
on the Flutter team.
So today, I will talk about
API usability and some lessons
I have learned from doing API
usability studies on Flutter
and through observing how people
actually use the API that we're
providing the SDK.
So why is API
usability important?
It's because API
usability issues
can lead to bugs in your
code, and some of those bugs
can be mission-critical.
And it also makes programming
less efficient and less
enjoyable for other people.
But when we talk
about API usability,
it's actually not
just one thing.
And we need to care about
three complementary areas.
And they're API
design, tools that
make APIs discoverable
and usable,
as well as documentation,
which explains
how to use APIs and libraries.
And often, you can find
that one API usability
issue can be solved
in many different ways
within this space.
So how can we make
APIs more usable?
Here, I share some lessons we
have learned from UX research
on Flutter.
The first lesson
is reducing context
switching during programming.
And here, I specifically
mean programmers
can move much faster if they
don't have to leave their code
editor to look for
the information they
need for a problem they
encounter during programming.
That's why it's pretty
common to see programmers
where they look for information
in the source code of thr ID,
instead of going to
their web browser
and look for online references.
So having a lot of documentation
is obviously a great thing
to have.
But what matters more is how
and where the user of the API
is going to access most relevant
information during programming.
I'm a strong believer in
high-quality API documentation
in the source code
itself, because that way,
you don't require
the user of your API
to switch a context to somewhere
else and risk not getting back
to the original task.
The second lesson is
that, as API designers,
we should help users build a
clear mental model when they're
dealing with complex APIs.
So in a recent UX
study we ran, we
observed that participants
had trouble understanding
how different building
blocks in Flutter animations
were related to one other.
And you can see that you have
to really digest these concepts.
So one potential way
to address this issue
is to visualize the conceptual
model of such a complex API
using a visual
representation, like this one,
and then map different APIs to
draw in the parts of this model
and also leverage some
familiar mental models
that the user may already have.
The third lesson is speaking
your users' language.
Anyone knows what the Block
widget does in Flutter?
It's OK if you don't have a
clue, because nobody really
knows.
[LAUGHTER]
But if I ask you about
this widget instead,
who knows what ListView does?
I bet many of you do.
But you probably didn't know
that Block was the old name
of ListView until early 2017.
So very early on, we found
that users really could not
find Block when they were
trying to find a widget that
can scroll a list of things.
And then we changed the name
and made the widget much easier
to discover.
And the next lesson is enable
programming by example.
Everyone loves
examples, but that
does not mean having a
bunch of examples somewhere
is good enough.
We used to have a feature
that we thought was clever.
We had a link on our website,
which will allow the user
to search for all the usage of
an API inside of the Flutter
repository.
But the result?
That it only
overwhelmed our users,
because there were so
many, and none of those
had screenshots to tell
you which one is the one
you are looking for.
As this study
participant pointed out,
it's kind of overwhelming.
So what did we realize?
That having a curated and
focused simple code in the API
documentation itself
and in the same time
provide screenshots,
illustrations, to show
the output of that piece
of code is really important
to guide the user and to help
them quickly understand what
an API does and decide
whether this sample code is
relevant to their task or not.
The last lesson I'd
like to share today
is that the API and
tooling should really
promote recognition,
rather than recall.
As an example, probably a lot of
you have used this Colors API.
But this API used
to require the user
to remember specific values for
different shades of the color,
and it also used a map
to store these colors,
store these values.
So you kind of need to
remember the specific number
to use this API.
And it also does not
autocomplete well,
because the map keys
don't autocomplete.
After realizing there was
a problem with this API,
we redesigned this API and
made sure all the shades
of a particular color would
show up in the autocomplete box
and also added a little preview
on the sidebar of the Code
Editor to tell you which exact
shade that you have selected.
So these changes have turned
a pretty expensive recall
operation in the user's head
to a less expensive recognition
operation in the user's head.
And this is also a case
where API redesign can really
enable tooling.
So these are the five lessons I
wanted to share with you today.
And you, as our
community, can really
help us make a difference by
reporting issues in usability
from your own experience,
and give us your ideas,
and potentially submit PRs
to fix some of the issues.
And there is an unconference
session tomorrow on this topic,
if you are interested
in further discussions.
Please come.
I think it's at 2:30.
And thank you very much.
Looking forward to
further discussions.
[APPLAUSE]